trauma team
don't forget you're worth it
what's going on i live right upstairs
so keep on living stop minding other
people's biz
mendez hold on it's his neighbor got
another drive
is there anything i can do maybe
you know barry at all more or less
struck up a convo once or twice he's a
friend from the precinct
left the force not long ago he broke
down after his best friend died
we're worried he'll do something stupid
relax
petrova barry's got nerves of sting
he's just a spiteful old bastard mendez
could you check on him when he's chilled
down sure why not
it's not like we're miles apart thanks
just be patient cops fallen in rough
times can be
touchy let's see what i can do
hey barry everything all right in
i'm there take that as a yes
try again later
barry am i remembering that right
who is it v your neighbor from upstairs
remember me talked about preem rides
back then you were pumped about the
mizutani xi'an
i said it was for flash posers
you don't forget a gunk thing like that
you gave me this look
i was about to hightail it to the
badlands right then and there
i remember what do you want
you can't let yourself fall apart barry
not here not in night city
you're a badge x-badge but still
got to stay strong if you won't who will
now hold on a sec we barely know each
other and you just
rock up here talking to me about my
problems
where'd you get the idea something with
me was up you watching me
someone sent you away
[Music]
all right you got me your friends asked
me to drop in on you so i thought
hey why not he's a stand-up guy
who cares if he has shitty tastes when
it comes to street shredders
come back just to get your ass kicked
man
you really know how to cheer a guy up
maybe those two asshats really are
worried about me
all right then come on in
not like you'll change anymore hey you
never know
believe it all right
cyberware users to buy only from
licensed manufacturers
it's worth the investment numerous nomad
caravans have appeared near city limits
in north oak and
charter hill some reports suggest some
of the violent vagrants may have entered
night city despite the ncpd's best
i lost someone close to me too a damn
good friend
what do you mean too
it's about andrew he uh
told you about him best bud i ever had
known in my whole life only person i
could spill to without being judged
i'm guessing things of the ncpd haven't
changed the lake huh
one time a maelstrom ganger killed a
young kid
right in front of my eyes for shits and
giggles
i couldn't do [ __ ] the son of a [ __ ]
had corporal protection
typical our chief greases his palms with
an
anonymous donation and guess what
officially kid blew his own brains out
right in front of your eyes something
died in me then
i couldn't do it anymore
a few months later andrew passed and
everything went to [ __ ]
you didn't have anyone to unload on at
work how about petrova in mendes
petrova is a decent gal but she's not
good with this stuff
mendez just doesn't get it he thinks us
blues need to be tough
can't bear the sight of a kid getting
murdered born with [ __ ] jeans
according to him but you told him about
andrew
honestly thought about it a lot
anyway they don't know everything
better that way
can you tell me how andrew died does it
matter
normally from old age
it's no wonder seen as he was only a few
years younger than my grandma
dying of old age in night city
that merits a monument oh world should
gaze up at it and all
ash box in the nitch will have to do
so then andrew was more like a grandpa
to you than a friend
wouldn't go that far it was like a
i don't know a window into the past or
something he reminded me of my gram
grams
about our little talks
time when everything had its proper
place you know
he was the last living record
of those times
mendes doesn't know [ __ ] about life
everyone's got their limits
even him he just hasn't reached them
not like you what if he's right though
maybe my genes are soft don't only
the strongest survive if he felt nothing
that means his loss wouldn't have had
any meaning
i guess so thanks for the talk fee
i am i need time to take all this
in sure thing take care
city coroners have confirmed botulism as
the cause of death
he finally decided to get his [ __ ]
together but cry out loud mendez
but soak in that sun while you can
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go away leave me alone
don't do this
but i know she's watching you from on
high and that changes you
very much
oh
barry's not okay i mean if that tortoise
was the one thing that got him up in the
morning
no you're starting to get it his friends
have to know
hopefully it's not too late you know how
it goes stare too long into the abyss
the abyssal stare right back at you
taking a step into it wouldn't be so
drastic
considering the [ __ ] he's seen in his
lifetime
there's a cold front moving in prepare
for cooler conditions
as we head into the weekend
[Music]
where are you walking
very close all right
barry's in great shape so much so in
fact that
he preferred to talk to a tortoise
steady youtube
that's supposed to be funny the complete
opposite
it's sad as hell barry didn't handle
bat's life too well
he made fun of him so he stopped sharing
things
and apart from you guys all he had was a
tortoise
his best friend a memento of his grandma
until he died that is [ __ ]
i don't [ __ ] believe this you're
bullshitting me
got another dry sun-filled wheat coming
your way
niche in the columbarium speaks for
itself
why would he lie to us though he talked
about the tortoise like it was a normal
person
i just think mendes would react to barry
admitted that he was talking to animals
jesus baron i thought he was being a
drama queen and he'd get over it
i gotta go and talk to him about time
thanks for your help this is for your
trouble
when danger
don't forget
i already told you you ain't got a
warrant you ain't coming in
damn it barry can't we just talk
petrova told me your last case was a
real ball buster
boss told you to keep your lips sealed
huh had a similar situation once you
know
[ __ ] child killer dirt bag was on the
petrochem board
so it was out of our hands remember it
to this day
a little kid's t-shirt green with this
funny yellow cat
get in